it is a mixed bag in terms of the
picture into it in terms of inflation we
have seen a slight fall not as much as
some people were expecting in the CPI
array but of course everyone's attention
focusing on that 19.1 rise in the cost
of food for some people a lot of things
are no unaffordable you know we have an
inflation crisis we're really worried
about what we're seeing with food prices
and we can all know that the Ukraine War
caused some of this but it's going on
for a lot longer and the government was
saying it would come down and it it's
remaining stubbornly high and I'm really
worried about families and pensioners
who are going to the supermarkets
they're seeing the price of bread the
price of cheese Staples continue rising
at record levels I mean there's an
interesting letter has been written to
the government by the Joseph branchery
foundation and others suggesting that
Universal Credit actually be tied to the
cost of essential Goods nine and ten
people they say that are currently on
Universal Credit going without at least
one of the items that they identify as
essential what do you make of that as an
idea well I think people should listen
to Joseph Roundtree we'll look at the
idea but they are champions in
understanding how people who are
vulnerable are faring whether it's
people on Universal Credit disabled
people elderly people and the government
just hasn't done enough there are many
people out there who are really really
in crisis we're seeing record numbers
going to food banks all the warnings I
see whether it's in my own consistency
or frankly across the country as I go
around in the local elections the cost
of living is the thing that people are
worried about alongside the NHS crisis I
wanted to talk to you actually about
those those set of local elections we'll
talk about what actually might happen in
in just a second but but a kind of a
threema thread we've been pulling on uh
here in breakfast this week has been
voter identification the necessity for
photo ID to be able to cast your vote
where are you I suspect I know where the
liberal Democrats are well we voted
against it yeah I think it's wrong the
government have failed to make the case
they claim it was about voter fraud
there's no evidence about this at all
and it will make it harder for some
people to vote and when you look at the
sort of things they've done in in
implementing this they've made it okay
for retired people to use their bus
passing it's great I think that's right
for photo ID for older people if we were
to have this awful system but they've
not allowed young people to use their
bus passes as photo ID that is very
suspicious and I think it suggests that
the government's motives behind this
change have nothing to do with voter
fraud they're everything to do with the
selfish interest of the conservative
party but we might not get a proper
indication of course until the next
general election turned out certainly
for local elections dramatically lower
than than we expect at generals I do
Wonder though how are the lib Dems going
to be getting on we have from the
conservative party chairman at the
weekend his view is that they will be
losing probably in excess of of a
thousand seats I mean the lib Dem is
going to be picking up are you going to
be winning here there everywhere well I
think the little Democrats will make
some real gains uh four years ago we
made massive gains to 700 games so we're
going to do even better than that
um but when we knock on doors uh across
the country and I'm going around around
England many of the local election
fights we're seeing lifelong
conservatives really angry with the
government
well they think they betray them the
cost of living we're just talking about
inflation food prices but they're
worried about the Health Service you
know they can't get an appointment with
the GP ambulance delays record waiting
times for for appointments it's part of
that not just general fatigue with the
government that has been in for the best
part of a decade and a half well I think
it's because the government made these
promises on the Health Service on police
and they failed to deliver very really
badly I mean to take police for example
they promised more police officers they
haven't arrived the numbers promised
we're seeing real problems uh for
example police are not attending
burglaries when people being the victims
of of burglary and that's why little
Democrats have been campaigning on
police alongside health and alongside
the need to help people with the cost of
living crisis but I suspect you're not
going to do as Greg Hans did and provide
me a figure that we can measure the lib
Dem success or otherwise at this at the
local elections well and not because I
don't take the voices for granted we're
going to be working right up to the
close of polls but you are going to be
you are going to make significant gains
we are going to make games absolutely I
think the conservative story in
expectation management they're trying to
play with everybody saying it's going to
be even worse than it might be who knows
what I do know is that liberal Democrats
are campaigning hard we've got lots of
great candidates up down the country
we're feeling more candidates than we've
done for for over a decade decade we're
excited because we've got lots of local
people community activists who want to
represent their community and make that
Community voice heard so I think the
liberal Democrats will do well
um of course you're a leader of the
liberal Democrats nationally and I
wonder if you have any sympathy for the
man who who leads the snps indeed a
first minister of Scotland Hamza Yusuf
finding himself in a bit of a bit of a
sticky situation do you think given the
allegations that have circled so close
to Nicholas sturgeon that the
appropriate thing to do at this point
would be for the SNP leader to suspend
her from the party
well I'm not close enough to the details
so it's wrong for me to comment to be
honest and given that there are strict
rules on police investigations it also
would be very unwise for anyone to
comment on that what we are seeing
though is the yesterday just in general
when people when people get arrested for
crimes is there not is there not then a
necessity on the party on any party
leadership to look at the allegations
and make a decision on suspension not
expulsion suspension at least well as a
leader of the liberal Democrats when we
see that we take it very very seriously
we act very very quickly but I'm not
going to comment if you don't mind on
police investigations ongoing that will
be wrong but I think what we what I can
comment on is what I'm seeing in
Scottish politics I'm seeing an SMP that
is very divided I think they're focusing
on issues that aren't the main issues
the Scottish people which are like
England right the cost of living they're
the Health Service they're things like
sewage and the environment and the SMP
governance is too divided to tackle
those they remind me how say of the
conservatives who are divided who are
factualized who are in fighting who uh
both the tourists and the SMP seem
riddled with Scandal so you know whether
it's in Scotland or in across the UK I
hope we can get rid of both the
conservatives and the SMP at the next
election good good luck with that one it
might be a little bit of an uphill no we
are going to work very hard and if
people want to get rid of the
conservatives in many parts of the
country epicities at local elections
they need to vote liberal Democrat we
are the main challenges to conservatives
in huge numbers of of seats and um I
hope they'll vote for the liberal
Democrat for our positive policies on
the Health Service on the economy and so
on but if they just want to get rid of
the conservatives the liberal Democrat
vote is the powerful vote in many areas
of the country so David great to have
you on this offer this morning thanks
for coming thank you